good morning John as you know I spent
the first twenty two years of my life
living in Florida where there are 43
million bugs per square centimeter in
the winter is the best time of the year
because you could move around without
getting sweaty and then in 2003 I moved
to Missoula Montana which was a ship
usually hovers around the 20s and 30s in
the winter sometimes it gets down to
like a negative 20 that's about as cold
as again and there are lots of people
who told me the secrets to living in a
cold place and their secrets weren't
secret everybody told me it's layers the
secret is layers like oh I never would
have guessed that wearing more clothes
would have but nobody said the secret is
don't touch metal with your bare hands
because they were like why would anyone
do that I'm from Florida pretend I'm a
baby so from person who has made a
successful transition from living in a
warm climate - loving cold weather here
are the actual secrets thirty degrees is
not cold I'm talkin Fahrenheit here
thirty degrees is at most chilly the
difference between 60 and 30 I knew that
that was a big difference what I did not
understand is the difference between
thirty and zero is the same size I just
thought it was all I got cold and then
it was cold forever know the difference
between 20 and negative 20 is very big
like life-threatening ly big cold begins
when it is physically painful to have
exposed skin very cold begins around
zero degrees Fahrenheit and below very
cold we have what's called too cold
which is a temperature that you should
not go out in unless you have become an
expert in existing at that temperature
number two walking on ice is something
that you just get better at as you try
to do it but it is very dangerous these
are called traction cleats they're
sometimes also called crampons
even though crampons are technically a
separate thing which are used for
climbing on ice and I assume also murder
they're not cheap but they're cheaper
than a broken arm if you know it's gonna
snow pull your wipers up so that they
don't freeze to the windshield and then
break when you try to chip them off
gloves are not for making your hands
warm once they are cold
this was very confusing to me gloves
keep your hands warm put them on before
your hands
cold also this is a fun tip if you put
your glove on before you put your jacket
on it makes a seal between the glove and
the jacket it's all about having good
seals I never understood scarves I
didn't know what scarves were for this
is a scarf this is the easiest way to
put on a scarf there's like a thousand
million others but scarves are there to
create the seal between your jacket and
your neck also you can sometimes pull
them up and do one of these don't lick
your lips a bunch that's a disaster my
big cold jacket 100% of the time there's
a chapstick in the pocket December is
the beginning of winter if you're in the
late January where we are right now and
you think that winter is almost over you
are going to be very upset when April
rolls around sunlight is important if
it's sunny out and there's no wind it
could be like t-shirt weather in the 30s
also seeing the Sun and feeling it on
your skin makes you much less miserable
wind is much more important than the Sun
if it's if it's in the teens and windy
just give up I'm not going to talk much
about driving except to say it's
different go slow and also you need one
of these
they're extremely inexpensive and you
should probably buy two because if it
breaks then suddenly you have a fifteen
thousand dollar piece of equipment that
you cannot operate because of the lack
of a four dollar piece of equipment also
don't buy that super short ones I don't
even know why they sell though I almost
forgot an important one do not turn your
heater off if you go on vacation your
pipes will explode and your house will
be destroyed likewise don't accidentally
leave a gallon of milk in the back of
the car Yelp and finally try to enjoy
it's very pretty it's a little
refreshing it feels very clean the Sun
sometimes comes out and that's nice even
if it's just a walk in the park
appreciate it if only like a teeny teeny
bit because otherwise you will resent it
a lot John I'll see you on Tuesday